If you want to know more about some of the
ties among the first three Child’s Play
movies that you might not have known about,
then stick around to end of this video.
We pick up right where we left off -- yeah
I’m just jumping into this -- at the factory
from the end of Child’s Play 2, only a lot
of time has passed and it’s now shut down.
The opening titles are very Halloween, but
instead of showing the decomposing pumpkin
in reverse, we see the plastic melting in
reverse, and also being infused with Chucky’s
cursed blood or whatever.
I don’t know, this is the dumbest method
of resurrection for Chucky yet -- and I think
that’s saying a lot.
We find out that the company behind the Good
Guy dolls are thinking about bringing them
back, and Mr. Sullivan, our buddy from the
second movie makes the final call.
He has a conversation with one of the other
executives.
“Well, if there’s nothing else, I’m
gonna get going.”
“It’s just my wife’s expecting me.
It’s our anniversary.”
This is a direct parallel to the executive
who gets killed early on in Child’s Play
2.
“The vodka.
Oh the vodka, of course I remembered the vodka.
Two week anniversary, you think I’d forget
the vodka?
So apparently there’s also a cut scene from
that movie where he immediately calls his
wife after that and tells her he’ll be home
late.
So I guess the two-week anniversary is like
how long he’s been smashing his assistant.
But back to Child’s Play 3. Looking around
Mr. Sullivan’s office, there are a few set
pieces that foreshadow the events that would
later take place.
For example, this ferris wheel precedes the
final sequence taking place at a fair.
This toy army man is a hint that the movie
will take place in a military school.
If we pause as the camera sweeps by Mr. Sullivan’s
computer, you may see a text document called
Barclay.doc alongside some numerical information.
This is the same computer that Chucky uses
to find Andy’s location, so it seems like
the company may be keeping tabs on him to
make sure he doesn’t do anything else to
possibly damage their profit lines any further.
That might be the creepiest thing in the movie
actually, imagine this corporation secretly
tracking your every move for 8 years after
one of their dolls tried to kill you.
In the last two Things You Missed episodes,
I mentioned the potential mistake on the Good
Guys boxes, where it said Play Partners Toys
instead of Play Pals Toys, which is the name
of the company.
In this movie though, there seems to be more
products with Play Partners listed on the
box, so I’m starting to think maybe this was not
a mistake.
Maybe Play Partners is the parent company
of Play Pals or something.
Chucky attacks Mr. Sullivan using an army
of his own toys, a fitting death considering
he knowingly put a dangerous product on the
market in the last movie.
Chucky chokes him to death, and his line,
“just like the good old days,” is a reference
to him being a criminal known as The Lakeshore
Strangler prior to the events of the first
one.
We catch up with Andy as he rolls into the
military school, which looks like it’s in
Missouri based on this license plate.
Too bad for Andy, because St. Louis is boring.
“Who would want to play in St. Louis?
So boring.
So boring.”
Speaking of boring, the newspaper article
that the Colonel has in Andy’s file is the
most boring and vague article I’ve ever
read, and it actually just repeats the same
paragraphs over and over.
I guess when you force out three movies in
three years though, this is the kind of quality
you get from your art department.
That being said, there is something of note
in the headline text, which reads: “Deaths
still unresolved.
Mother under psychiatric care.”
This suggests that although we may not have
seen it in the other movies, there may have
been some uncertainty in the public eye about
whether Andy’s mom actually deserved to
be institutionalized.
If the case is still open, that means they
may still be investigating.
Andy is forced to get his hair cut for military
school, and in the barber shop there are some
cadets whose locks are on display on the wall.
Many of their names are jokes or pop culture
references.
I saw a Mr. Smells, Mr. Hurts, Stud, Wile
E. Coyote, Bruce Willis and Tommy Lee Jones.
There’s also a dart board in the room behind
Sgt.
Botnik’s head.
This could be a symbol for him being Chucky’s
future target, especially considering the
fact that Chucks has already used darts as
weapons earlier in the movie against Mr. Sullivan.
The sergeant tells Andy about how the Romans
invented the military cut so that their enemies
couldn’t grab ahold of it in battle and
slit their throats.
The strategy didn’t really work out for
him though, because he later meets his fate
when he gets his throat slit by Chucky while
trying to give him a buzz.
As he’s getting his trim, a Good Guys episode
comes on the TV and it’s the same episode
from the first movie; we get to see a little
more of it on camera this time around.
TV: "We're back and we're better than ever."
"No one will play with me."
"Uh-oh, there's a friend in need."
This kid Tyler even has a similar reaction
to Andy, when he first saw the commercial.
Tyler: "Wooooowwwww!!!"
Andy: "Wow!"
Owen Wilson: "Wow."
So Chucky ends up mailing himself to Andy,
but Tyler ends up opening the box instead.
I have some serious questions about how Chucky
was able to wrap up this package if he
was inside of it.
And then put that package in the mail.
And pay for postage.
But let’s just ignore those things and get
to the part where Chucky reveals his true
self to Tyler and tries to do the ritual to
possess his body.
The Colonel shows up and interrupts things
by taking Chucky away.
“I’ll be back.”
I think this is kind of a Terminator reference.
"I'll be back"
Chucky and the Terminator are both kind of
robotic killers in a way -- the main difference
being that Chucky is slowly turning human.
Andy’s roommate Whitehurst tells Andy he
needs to unpack, which may or may not be an
intentional reference to Mrs. Simpson telling
Kyle to unpack in the previous movie; but
Andy unpacks his stuff and we see that he’s
got a magazine called Play Pen.
It seems Andy has grown up and moved from
Play Pals to Play Pen, and the text on the
front of the magazine says, “come play with
me,” just as the Good Guy box says, “hi,
I’m a Good Guy, let’s play.”
Andy is left alone in the room with Chucky,
but the drill leader, Shelton, barges in and
steals the doll as a present for his younger
sister and Andy is finally smart enough now
to know that most people will think he’s
insane if he tells them the truth about Chucky.
So instead, Andy tries to warn Tyler that
Chucky will come after him, but not before
the Colonel sees Chucky moving around and
has a heart attack as a result.
Then Chucky slits the throat of the barber,
Sgt.
Botnik, as I mentioned earlier.
So it all comes down to this thing they do
called The War Games, which is basically capture
the flag meets paintball.
My parents always used to use military school
as a punishment threat whenever I got in trouble,
like “you better be good or we’re gonna
have to send you to military school!”
And I always thought that would have been
like the worst punishment you could get as
kid, but judging from this movie it… looks
kind of fun.
I mean you get to camp out and possibly command
your own little army unit with paintballs
and walkie talkies.
I’d take that over sitting in a classroom
and watching Bill Nye the Science Guy all
day.
But it’s all fun and games until Chucky
brings in… a real grenade?
Why does the school even have this?
It’s like the whole shock device from the
first one all over again.
Also, what happened to Chucky’s teeth?
Looks like that one lady I pointed out in
the Black Christmas episode.
Anyway, after Chucky tries to kill them all
with the grenade and Whitehurst takes one
for the team, Tyler realizes, “you know
what?
Maybe this Barclay kid was right.
Maybe this Chucky guy isn’t such a good
guy.”
I mean, he is technically a Good Guy…
Just forget I said that...
Tyler flees to the fair and Chucky makes him
go into this dark ride called The Devil’s
Lair, and let me just say, THIS is an AWESOME
looking ride.
This is way above the quality I would expect
from a carnival attraction.
This is some Haunted Mansion level ****.
Part 1 of the ride is in a graveyard, representing
Chucky’s numerous victims over the three
films.
Part 2 takes place in hell, representing Andy’s
personal hell of once again being hunted by
Chucky after he thought it was over 8 years
ago.
Chucky’s ritual is once again interrupted
when he dives out of the way because he doesn’t
want to be seen by the people on the ride,
but honestly I don’t know why.
He’s basically no different than an animatronic
-- he’d fit right here.
Then he gets his face sliced open by this
reaper’s scythe… you know because, they
used a real scythe to decorate this ride.
But that doesn’t stop him from making one
more attempt to take over Tyler’s body,
during which Andy shoots him and blows off
his right arms, something that happens to
Chucky in all three movies.
After that, Andy shoots him in the heart,
which makes sense because that’s what worked
in the first movie, but apparently that just
doesn’t work anymore, cause, you know.
CONTINUITY.
So the key this time is to knock Chucky into
a high speed fan and let it shred him up,
and the shot symbolically represents Chucky
falling into the pits of hell.
The movie ends on another symbolic shot.
It’s one I was hesitant to bring up in my
video on the second movie: the carousel.
In the previous video I talked about how the
carousel represents Andy going around and
around to different homes and never settling
in because Chucky always comes after him and
ruins it for it for him.
So he continues to go around this endless
circle.
The music at the end seems to suggest that
Chucky isn’t done for good, with the carousel
telling us it’s business as usual for Andy
Barclay.
That brings us to the conclusion of the original
Child’s Play series -- but we’ve got a
remake on the way very shortly, so make sure
you subscribe to CZsWorld so you don’t miss out on
the next episode of Things You Missed where
I’ll be covering the 2019 Child’s Play.
Make sure you ring the deathbell for notifications
and I’ll see you then, assuming we both
survive.